[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend in allen wir stellen das Wohl der
Kinder in den Mittelpunkt so ein Satz
klingt gut in jeder Wahlkampfrede jetzt
zeigt sich was konkret daraus wird die
Ampelkoalition war ja angetreten mit dem
Versprechen die Armut der kleinen in
diesem Land energisch zu bekämpfen ein
großer Wurf sollte das werden die
sogenannte Kindergrundsicherung die
grüne Familienministerin hatte für die
Finanzierung des Projekts ursprünglich
12 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr gefordert im
Haushaltsplan stehen aktuell gerade mal
zwei Milliarden als Platzhalter wenn das
so bleibt steht das wichtigste
sozialpolitische Vorhaben der Grünen auf
der Kippe weiteren Zündstoff in der
Koalition gibt es heute weil die
Familienministerin auf der anderen Seite
erhebliche Einschnitte plant beim
Elterngeld entscheidende Tage also
gerade für die Familien in Deutschland
Heikes lanski
Endspurt im politischen Berlin vor der
Sommerpause es geht um die Kinder
Grundsicherung und die Deutungshoheit
seit Monaten ein strittiges Vorhaben
innerhalb der Ampel gestern hatte sich
der Kanzler eingemischt die Grünen
werten das als Rückenwind für ihre
Ministerin der Kanzler hat ja jetzt ganz
klar seine Unterstützung für die
Kindergrundsicherung zum Ausdruck
gebracht er hat sich an die Seite der
Familienministerin gestellt und hat
gesagt ich will dass dieses Projekt bis
zum Ende des Sommers abgeschlossen ist
und ich will auch
Leistungsverbesserungen an dieser Stelle
tatsächlich hat der Kanzler die
Ministerin schriftlich gebeten zügig
einen Gesetzentwurf zu erarbeiten und
die noch fehlenden Regelungen zu
ergänzen für die beabsichtigten
Leistungsverbesserung bittet er
Alternativen zu erarbeiten
zum einen verstehe ich auch den
Bundeskanzler so dass es jetzt darum
geht ein Konzept für die
Kindergrundsicherung endlich
vorzustellen es geht um Digitalisierung
und entbürokratisierungs bringt ja nicht
zu mein Geld in den Haushalt einstellt
aber es bei den Familien gar nicht
ankommt das ist zurzeit der Fall und das
müssen wir dringend ändern 12 Milliarden
fordert die Familienministerin lediglich
2 Milliarden will der Finanzminister
locker machen die spd-interpretiert den
Auftrag des Kanzlers ähnlich wie die FDP
eine Verwaltungsreform statt mehr Geld
für armutsgefährdete Kinder das ist eben
keine finanzielle Debatte ist sondern
insbesondere strukturelle Fragen das
haben jetzt offensichtlich die
Beteiligten auch verstanden und was dann
noch finanzielle notwendig ist das
werden wir uns dann noch mal vor Augen
führen der Streit ums Geld geht in die
nächste Runde Grüne und FDP im
Dauerclinch weiterer soft droht wegen
des Elterngeldes die Familienministerin
will das für besser Hände streichen um
die Sparvorgaben für den kommenden
Haushalt zu erfüllen Schuldzuweisungen
der Finanzminister hat jetzt der
Familienministerin diesen Vorschlag
gemacht beim Elterngeld zu kürzen aus
gleichstellungspolitischer Sicht ist das
aus meiner Sicht nicht der beste
Vorschlag den er an der Stelle machen
konnte ich will in aller Kleid sagen
dass lehnen die Freien Demokraten in
dieser Form ab bevor man bei Eltern
kürzt sollte man lieber im eigenen
Ministerium aus meiner Sicht sparen im
übrigen sind auch Ausgaben vorgesehen
wie ich glaube für politische
fragwürdige und teilweise ineffiziente
Programme
Koalitionsstreit ausgetragen auf offener
Bühne das sozialpolitische
Aushängeschild der Ampel die Kinder
Grundsicherung vertagt die Rollen
verteilt für ein bevorstehendes
Sommertheater
ja da gibt's noch einiges zu diskutieren
aber worum geht es im Detail da lohnt
sich mal näher drauf zu gucken die
Kinder Grundsicherung soll die
Leistungen des Staates für Familien
bündeln einfacher machen und
digitalisierter und noch Vorstellung der
Grünen fachministerin auch erhöhen
Dominik erstmal erklärt
[Musik]
oft ist Familien gar nicht bewusst dass
sie Anspruch auf Unterstützung haben zu
kompliziert zu bürokratisch die vielen
Leistungen den Kinderzuschlag beantragt
und erhält zum Beispiel nur etwa jedes
dritte Anspruchsberechtigte Kind in
Deutschland
vorgesehen bei der Kindergrundsicherung
sind zwei Komponenten ein
einkommensunabhängiger garantiebetrag
soll für alle Kinder gezahlt werden
zunächst auf Höhe des heutigen
Kindergeldes von 250 € pro Kind und
Monat außerdem ist ein Zusatzbetrag
geplant er soll das Existenzminimum des
Kindes Abdecken der Geldbetrag richtet
sich nach dem Alter des Kindes und wie
viel die Eltern verdienen das Geld soll
fließen bis das Kind 18 ist mit
Ausbildung oder Studium bis zum 25
geburtstag
Familienministerin Pauls geht von
Zusatzkosten von 12 Milliarden Euro pro
Jahr aus dadurch dass viele die bisher
kein Geld beantragt haben was bekommen
außerdem will sie die Leistungen für
Familien wegen der hohen Inflation
generell anheben
bei der Kindergrundsicherung soll aus
der bisherigen hohlschuld der Bürger
eine Bringschuld des Staates werden
einer Bringschuld des Staates für mehr
als jedes fünfte Kind unter 18 in diesem
Land insgesamt fast drei Millionen
Mädchen und Jungen die von Armut bedroht
sind das heißt in der Definition ihre
Familie hat weniger als 60% des
mittleren deutschen Haushaltseinkommens
zur Verfügung mit Summen Statistiken
Definitionen allein kommen wir aber
nicht weiter wer als Kind in Armut
aufwächst in diesem reichen
Industrieland hat ganz konkrete
Erfahrungen Mangel Verzicht und Scham um
ihrer rein und ihre Reportage jetzt aus
Hamburg
seit vielen Jahren kommen Briana Bethany
und brendolin schon in die Arche hier
kriegen Sie kostenloses Mittagessen
besonders jetzt wo Lebensmittel so teuer
sind eine große Entlastung für ihre
Mutter denn die zieht ihre drei Töchter
allein groß und lebt vom Bürgergeld
was ist eine großartige Unterstützung
vor allem ich muss nicht jeden Tag dem
Kochen weil ich weiß die Kinder haben
hier was zu essen und auch Unterstützung
beim Hausaufgaben alles es macht die
Arche dann auch mit den Kindern zusammen
hilft dir viel also das heißt ich bin
dann ein bisschen oder bzw ich bin da
nicht überfordert mit dem ganzen
Schulaufgaben also ich weiß wie die
hierher kommen kriegt auch hier die
unterstützen damit es für mich auch in
einen leichterung wird wenn die Gedanken
ständig ums Geld Kreisen die zwei Zimmer
Wohnung einfach zu klein ist und die
eigene Mutter pflegebedürftig dann ist
jede Unterstützung willkommen Madeleine
versucht jeden Cent zu sparen doch bei
Kosten die nicht einkalkuliert sind
hilft auch das nicht viel ich stecke
gerade da also ich stecke jetzt fest
muss ich sagen ja man Waschmaschine ist
jetzt kaputt und ich bin die ganze Zeit
überlegen das heißt ich muss irgendwie
wieder zum Waschcenter gehen was ist
auch nicht so günstig
Anfang dieses Jahres hat die
Bundesregierung das Kindergeld auf 250
Euro erhöht davon hat die Hamburgerin
nichts denn es wird in voller Höhe aufs
Bürgergeld angerechnet dass die Kinder
Grundsicherung nun gezielt von Armut
betroffenen Familien helfen soll begrüßt
die Arche und hat auch eine ganz
konkrete Forderung 600 € pro Kind wir
wünschen uns auch eine Splittung
vielleicht zwischen Geld was direkt in
der Familie direkt beim Kind ankommt und
Geld was Schulen und Kindertagesstätten
oder auch Kinder und Jugendeinrichtungen
stärkt damit Förderung dort vor Ort an
möglichst viele Kinder auch
weitergegeben werden kann das durch die
Bündelung der verschiedenen Leistungen
auch viel Papierkram wegfallen soll
findet Madeleine adjumangen gut das ist
eine große leichter und dann wir wissen
hier in Deutschland ist so viel
bürokratischen Sachen es ist Bürokratie
ich wünsche mir schon dass man
vielleicht noch so ein bisschen
mehr Leistung bekommt und vielleicht
eine große Wohnung zu finden war
manchmal ist sie ja so man sucht zwar
eine Wohnung aber es ist sehr schwer war
das was man gerade bekommt eben halt zu
wenig ist das nicht ausreicht und
meistens kriegt man dann eine Absage
weil man einfach zu wenig hat trotz
vieler Herausforderungen engagiert
Madeleine ajumang sich auch für andere
das Haus am See ist ein Ort der
Begegnung gefördert von der Stadt
Hamburg hier unterstützt sie bei der
Organisation des familienbuffets erhält
dafür eine kleine Aufwandsentschädigung
das Treffen ist wertvoll gerade für jene
die wenig Geld haben und für die
gesellschaftliche Teilhabe oft nicht
möglich ist
es ist mir auch wichtig dass die Leute
auch wirklich mit uns reden gucken
was kann ich mich erleichtern in mein
Leben Erleichterung erhofft sich
Madeleine auch von einer kommenden
Kindergrundsicherung für ein
sorgenfreies Leben
unser nächstes Thema Israels Armee
spricht von einer Anti Terroraktion
intern heißt sie Operation Heim und
Garten das partizellensische
Außenministerium nennt es offenen Krieg
gegen die Bewohner von Jenny
Luftangriffe und gefechte am Boden seit
fast 20 Jahren seit den dunkelsten
Zeiten der zweiten in die Fada hat es
keinen derartigen israelischen
Militäreinsatz gegeben im
palästinensischen Westjordanland und er
bringt ein ohnehin äußerst labiles
Gefüge an den Rand der Katastrophe die
Palästinensische Autonomiebehörde samt
Präsident denen Israel mal einen eigenen
Staat versprochen hatte sieht dabei noch
machtloser und schwächer aus als ohnehin
schon der Terror militanter
Palästinenser Gruppen geht weiter
zuletzt heute Mittag in Tel Aviv von
dort Michael Beverungen
der Terror ist zurück in Tel Aviv von
einer Sekunde auf die andere
ein Auto rast in eine Bushaltestelle
Menschen fliegen durch die Luft andere
flüchten in Panik der Attentäter steigt
aus dem Auto und geht mit einem Messer
auf die Verletzten los bevor er von
einem Zivilisten erschossen wird neuen
zum Teil schwer Verletzte darunter ein
Kind es ist Teil der Tragödie das ganz
Israel so etwas erwartet hatte nur Zeit
und Ort kannte niemand
zum Glück war ein Zivilist bewaffnet er
konnte den Terroristen neutralisieren
schnell ist auch ein rechter
Scharfmacher vor Ort und beansprucht die
Deutungshoheit
itamabengwirr Chef der siedlerpartei
jüdische Stärke ich rufe alle Bürger
Israels auf tragt Waffen retten Leben
verhindert aber haben das Attentat diese
Waffen nicht und auch nicht wenn wir's
Politik der Härte er werde für Ordnung
und Sicherheit sorgen hatte er im
Wahlkampf versprochen und dann als
Minister für nationale Sicherheit
versagt schon zur Jahresmitte gibt es so
viele Tote und Verletzte Israelis die
seit Jahren nicht
und so viele Tote und Verletzte
Palästinenser die seit zehn Jahren nicht
auch der Waffeneinsatz gegen Terroristen
in gengen kann den Terror nicht gänzlich
stoppen nicht einmal die größte
Militäroperation investitionenland seit
dem Ende der zweiten in die fördert 2015
Israels führen sie trotzdem einen Erfolg
mehrere Sprengstoff Labore und viele
Waffen sein beschlagnahmt oder zerstört
worden viele Verdächtige verhaftet
ich gratuliere unseren tapferen Kämpfern
die ingenieuristische Infrastrukturen
zerstört und dadurch viele Anschläge
verhindert haben in diesem Moment
schließen wir unsere Mission ab
doch auch nach einem möglichen Abzug
werden die Narben auf den Straßen des
Flüchtlingslagers noch lange sichtbar
bleiben nicht nur terroristische
Infrastruktur wurde zerstört sondern
auch zivile Wasser und Stromleitungen
und nicht nur die militanten Kämpfer
sind geflohen auch tausende Zivilisten
geblieben ist der Hass stärker als zuvor
seit gestern war es sehr schwer für uns
Drohnen haben auf uns geschossen jetzt
wollen wir nur noch weg wir sind nur
noch müde wir haben nichts zu essen oder
zu trinken
was also hat er erreicht der große
Militärschlag von Jeanine kurzfristig
sicher eine Schwächung der Terrorzellen
dort langfristig wenig Glauben
Sicherheitsexperten
der Einsatz in gengen kann den Terror
nicht eliminieren er kann ihn nicht
entwurzeln es gibt auch keine Hauptstadt
des teros der ist weit verbreitet in den
Herzen und Köpfen überall in
palästinensischen Sektor Investoren
noch dauern die Kämpfe ingenie an wieder
ein Tag an dem sich Israelis und
Palästinenser nur noch weiter entfremdet
haben
in Frankreich läuft eine Spendenaktion
für den Polizisten der einen 17-Jährigen
bei einer Verkehrskontrolle erschossen
hatte und da sind mittlerweile 1,5
Millionen Euro zusammengekommen die
Summe ist um ein Vielfaches höher als
die Spenden für die Familie des
Getöteten zur Beruhigung der Lage in
Frankreich dürfte das nicht beitragen
Hannah das ist dein Thema zu Beginn der
Nachrichtenübersicht jetzt und dennoch
hält der französische Präsident macron
den Höhepunkt der Ausschreitungen in
Frankreich nun für überschritten das
sagte er heute bei einem Treffen mit
mehr als 240 Bürgermeisterinnen und
Bürgermeister von besonders betroffenen
Städten dabei ging es auch um
Unterstützung für die Beseitigung von
Schäden und nötigen nötige Konsequenzen
seit Tagen kommt es in Frankreich zu
Krawallen auslöser war der Tod des
17-Jährigen bei einer Polizeikontrolle
russland hat auch heute wieder zivile
Ziele im Süden und Osten der Ukraine
angegriffen
sind nach ukrainischen Angaben in einem
Wohngebiet zwei Menschen getötet worden
in der Region wurden bei einer Explosion
mindestens 43 Menschen verletzt darunter
auch Kinder mehrere Wohnhäuser und Autos
wurden beschädigt offenbar war eine
Rakete eingeschlagen der Ort liegt mehr
als 100 km von der Front entfernt
die ampelfraktionen haben sich dagegen
ausgesprochen einen
Untersuchungsausschuss zum Steuerskandal
bei der Hamburger Warburg Bank und die
Rolle von Bundeskanzler Scholz
einzusetzen die Abstimmung erfolgte im
Geschäftsordnungsausschuss mit dem nein
dürfte es für das Vorhaben der Union
morgen auch im Bundestag keine Mehrheit
geben die ampelparteien halten den
Antrag für verfassungswidrig weil es um
Vorgänge im Land Hamburg gehe die Union
hat im Falle einer Blockade bereits den
Gang nach Karlsruhe angekündigt
das Bundesverfassungsgericht befasst
sich seit heute mit der Frage ob die NPD
die mittlerweile die Heimat heißt von
der staatlichen Parteienfinanzierung
ausgeschlossen werden kann Bundestag
Bundesrat und Bundesregierung hatten
dazu in Karlsruhe den Antrag gestellt
seit 2017 gibt es die Möglichkeit
Parteien die verfassungsfeindlich sind
von öffentlicher Förderung
auszuschließen damals hatten die
Karlsruher Richter der NPD eben dies
attestiert nun prüft das Gericht ob die
Verfassungsfeindlichkeit auch heute noch
besteht
die internationale Atome Energiebehörde
hat dem umstrittenen Plan Japans
zugestimmt verstrahltes Kühlwasser aus
dem havarierten Atomkraftwerk Fukushima
ins Meer zu leiten das Vorhaben
entsprechende internationalen
Sicherheitsstandards sagte Behördenchef
Rossi die radiologischen Auswirkungen
sein vernachlässigbar das belastete
Wasser das zur Kühlung der 2011
zerstörten Reaktoren genutzt wird soll
stark verdünnt im Meer entsorgt werden
der Grund ist Platzmangel japanische
Fischer so wie China und Südkorea
kritisieren die Pläne
der neue nato-chef ist der alte Jens
Stoltenberg macht weiter obwohl er das
eigentlich nicht wollte aber das
Militärbündnis hat ausgerechnet in der
aktuellen Zeit Schwierigkeiten eine
Nachfolge zu finden auf die sich alle
Mitgliedsstaaten einigen können so
klingt solltenbergs Aussage heute er sei
geehrt über die Vertragsverlängerung
nicht nach der ganzen Wahrheit zumal die
Entscheidung für die NATO nur
aufgeschoben ist und jetzt im kommenden
Jahr neu ansteht einem Jahr das viel
unberechenbarer werden dürfte als das
aktuelle Florian neuhahn mit mehr dazu
aus Brüssel
neulich auf Tour in Litauen da passiert
Jens deutenberg etwas was ihm gewöhnlich
nie passiert ein peinlicher Versprecher
was wir in Russland gesehen haben dass
demonstriert doch die Zerbrechlichkeit
des deutschen Regimes
Einwurf von Boris Pistorius des
deutschen Regimes
natürlich
Jens Stoltenberg seit 2014 an der Spitze
der NATO hat zwei Stärken er
funktioniert in dieser Krise wie ein
Schweizer Uhrwerk verlässlich fast
fehlerfrei einer der die Allianz
unermüdlich antreibt
aufstocken wir müssen mehr für unsere
Sicherheit ausgeben um unsere
Bevölkerung zu schützen müssen wir mehr
in Verteidigung investieren
zweite Stärke er kann auch mit
autoritären Staatschefs in den eigenen
Reihen mit dem aktuellen türkischen
Präsidenten Erdogan ebenso wie vor ein
paar Jahren mit einem US-Präsidenten der
die NATO für überflüssig hielt
mit das größte Verdienst war
dass er in der Zeit der Präsidentschaft
von Präsident Trump
die NATO schadlos durch diese Phase
geleitet hat weil es auch seins war und
ist dass die Europäer viel mehr in
Verteidigung investieren also vielen
mehr Finanzen dafür aufwenden das Lob
verdeckt was diese Verlängerung von
heute eigentlich ist eine Notlösung oder
gar ein Zeichen der Schwäche Kandidaten
gab es schließlich genug der britische
Verteidigungsminister Wallace abgelehnt
weil die EU-Staaten nach dem brexit
keinen Briten an der Spitze wollten die
estnische Premierministerin Callas
abgelehnt weil ihre harte Haltung zu
Russland nicht allen gefiel schließlich
die dänische Ministerpräsidentin
Fredericksen abgelehnt weil schon zu
viele Generalsekretäre aus Nordeuropa
kamen in der Natur funktioniert alles
nur ein stimmig getragen von allen 31
Staaten ein Veto kann alles Leben von
der Erweiterung bis zum Spitzenpersonal
und jetzt solltenberg ist jetzt erst
recht was sein wollte ein
Generalsekretär auf Abschiedstournee
natürlich stellt sich danach die Frage
noch mal wie geht es weiter dann geht
die Kandidatensuche noch mal los das
wird auch nicht einfacher in einem Jahr
in den USA gewählt wird und auch in
vielen europäischen Ländern gewählt wird
also dann ist zu sagen das Thema noch
mal offen kurzfristig hat die NATO heute
ein Problem gelöst und zugleich einen
deutlich größeres für 24 geschaffen wenn
in der EU und den USA gewählt wird und
die NATO zugleich jemanden braucht wenn
er geht
das made in germanyland guckt immer
gebannt auf seine Exportzahlen die haben
eine wichtige Rolle als Anzeichen dafür
wie gut oder eben wie schlecht die
Stütze der deutschen Konjunktur läuft im
letzten Jahr hatte der deutsche
Außenhandel noch einen Rekord-Ergebnis
erzielt heute kommt die Warnung die
Ausführung gehen wenn auch leicht zurück
es ist nur eines von vielen derartigen
wahnsignalen aus der Wirtschaft in
letzter Zeit eine Wirtschaft die vor
einer gewaltigen Umwälzung steht bzw
bereits mittendrin ist für die einen
große Chance für die anderen gewaltiges
Risiko Britta Buchholz
ein Traditionsunternehmen muss aufgeben
wieder einmal der Hersteller der Weg ein
machtgläser ist insolvent gerade die
Glasherstellung ist energieintensiv
damit steigen die Kosten vor dem Werk
kaufen Sie mit nostalgischen Gefühlen
ja aus diesem Grunde habe ich einen Weg
Gummis gekauft weil die Gläser werde ich
noch irgendwie und überall noch kriegen
aber wenn es keine Gummis mehr gibt dann
irgendwie Probleme beim einwecken
Energie intensive Unternehmen Kämpfe um
die Existenz ganze Branchen wie Chemie
Papier oder Aluminium haben es schwer
rentabel zu produzieren doch sie klagen
nicht nur über hohe Energiepreise
sondern auch über Bürokratie wenig
Fachkräfte und kaum Innovation
wenn wir in dieser Zeit in der wir
wissen dass wir eigentlich
Transformation benötigen sehen dass wir
kein Wirtschaftswachstum haben dann ist
das glaube ich wirklich ein Weckruf mit
dem wir uns sehr intensiv beschäftigen
müssen ein Weckruf den Weg in die
Transformation für den Bundeskanzler
aber eher eine Chance eins sagte er
wegen der hohen Investitionen in den
Klimaschutz wird Deutschland
Wachstumsraten erzielen können wie
zuletzt in den 1950er und 60er Jahren
da ist oder sollst du optimistisch und
liegt damit falsch und macht falsche
Hoffnungen für die Industrie das sind im
Sinkflug unterwegs verlieren jedes Jahr
ein Attraktivität Investoren wenden sich
ab die Industrie geht und dieses nun
herumdrehen in der Ampel brechen derweil
ideologische Grabenkämpfe auf wieder
einmal SPD und Grüne können sich
vorstellen den massiv gestiegenen
industriestrompreis mit Steuergeld zu
subventionieren ein teurer Plan
ich denke das Geld ist gut investiert
indem wir auch die energieintensiven
Unternehmen hier in Deutschland am
Standort halten und darum kämpfen dass
sie hier ihre grüne Transformation
durchführen wir haben jetzt eine
schwierige Umstellungsphase und die ist
nicht von den Unternehmen verschuldet
worden und erst recht nicht von den
Arbeitnehmern in diesen Unternehmen wir
müssen jetzt helfen dass solche
Unternehmen wie sie beschrieben habe
eine durchstrecke Überwinden der
Finanzminister meint dass er nicht
finanzierbar und hat wiederum eine
schwere finanzierbare Idee
wer etwas tun will beim Strompreis der
da habe ich eine Alternative schaffen
wir Prioritäten im Bundeshaushalt und
Senken für alle die Belastung durch die
Stromsteuer da haben wir entsprechende
Verzerrungen nicht ich wäre dazu bereit
ihm ist klar das ist mit SPD und grün
nicht denkbar und während die Ampel
keine Lösungen findet kommt ein
besorgniserregender Befund 16 Prozent
der Befragten mittelständischen
Unternehmen verlagern bereits Teile der
Produktion und Arbeitsplätze ins Ausland
weitere 30% denken darüber nach
wir sind jetzt darauf angewiesen dass
wir relativ schnell Klarheit schaffen
und relativ schnell Entscheidungen
treffen die den Unternehmen sozusagen
die Erwartungen geben dass relativ
schnell die Situation zum Beispiel an
den Strommärkten wieder aussichtsreich
ist noch glänzt Deutschland mit voll
Beschäftigung doch langfristig verändert
sich vieles Klimaneutralität als Chance
oder als Gefahr
ja wir bleiben nochmal mit bei der
Wirtschaft dass ich bei der Bahn
Grundlegendes ändern muss ist so klar
wie die Verspätung oder der zugausfall
bei einer nächsten Reise heute ein
Vorschlag der dann aber doch ziemlich
radikal klingt Hanna ja das kann man so
sagen die Monopolkommission die die
Bundesregierung in Wettbewerbsfragen
berät hat sich für einen Umbau der
Deutschen Bahn ausgesprochen konkret
dafür dass die infrastruktursparte vom
Rest des bundesebenen Konzerns
abgespalten wird da fragen wir nach bei
Valerie Haller in Frankfurt womit
begründet die Kommission diese Forderung
nun die Kommission sagt die Bahn braucht
dringend mehr Wettbewerb und Reformen
und das glauben die Experten kann es nur
geben wenn das Schienennetz aus dem
Konzern herausgelöst wird dann würde so
die Annahme auf den Strecken saniert und
gebaut eben dort wo es nötig ist und
nicht nur für die Bahn sondern eben auch
für private zugbetreiber gut ist hieße
mehr Wettbewerb der
Betrieb würde günstiger die Hoffnung ist
dass dann auch die Infrastruktur besser
wird weil es weniger Querfinanzierung
zwischen den einzelnen bahnsparten gäbe
Kritiker jedoch fürchten dadurch vor
allem Nachteile für die Beschäftigten
und andere sagen so eine Entflechtung
die würde Jahre dauern welche konkreten
Konsequenzen hat er nun dieser Vorschlag
keine direkten weil die
Monopolkommission ein Beratungsgremium
ist anders als das Bundeskartellamt kann
sie nicht direkt eingreifen Eingreifen
sie ist da eher vergleichbar mit dem
mahnenden Bundesrechnungshof aber ihr
Einfluss ist trotzdem nicht zu
unterschätzen ihr Vorschlag liegt nun
mal auf den Tisch wird aufgegriffen
medial verbreitet und diskutiert und das
alleine das gibt dem Urteil der
Monopolkommission schon Gewicht vielen
Dank Valerie nach Frankfurt
wegen des Messerangriffs auf zwei
Schülerinnen in Iller Kirchberg ist der
Angeklagte zu lebenslange Haft
verurteilt worden Mord und versuchter
Mord mit gefährlicher Körperverletzung
urteilte das Landgericht Ulm das zudem
eine besondere Schwere der Schuld
feststellte damit ist eine vorzeitige
Entlassung des 27-Jährigen aus Eritrea
so gut wie ausgeschlossen im Dezember
hatte er eine 14-Jährige getötet eine
13-Jährige konnte verletzt fliehen die
beiden waren Zufalls Opfer der Tat war
ein Behördenstreit um einen Pass
vorausgegangen
in Fertigprodukten für Kinder stecken
immer noch zu viel Zucker Fett und Salz
das ergab eine Untersuchung die
ernährungsminister mir heute vorgestellt
hat wer viele solche Produkte esse oder
trinke habe ein erhöhtes Risiko etwa für
Diabetes oder Übergewicht zuerstimir
Hersteller hätten es in der Hand
Rezepturen zu verbessern schon die
letzte Bundesregierung setzte auf eine
Selbstverpflichtung der Industrie
verbraucherschützer fordern verbindliche
Reduktionsziele
und jetzt zum Sport zur vierten Etappe
der Tour de France die erneut der
Belgier Jasper Philips in gewann aber
auch viel Bauhaus schaffte wieder den
Sprung aufs Podest mit Highspeed ging es
im Finale über die Rennstrecke von
Nogaro dabei kamen zahlreiche Fahrer zu
Fall am Ende erreichte der 28-Jährige
Bauhaus als dritter das Ziel auf Platz
zwei sprintete der Australia Evan dicht
hinter Philipsen
so und damit sagen wir zwei hier im
Namen des gesamten Teams danke für Ihr
Interesse die 37 Grad Reportage
begleitet gleich drei Familien im Ahrtal
die ihre Existenz neu aufbauen mussten
was wir retten konnten zwei Jahre nach
der Flutkatastrophe und außerdem noch
der Hinweis auf unser heute journal
Update gegen Mitternacht mit Gundula
Gause
[Musik]
guten Abend vor der Hitze am Wochenende
erreicht uns jetzt erstmal ein richtiges
Sturmtief das ist ungewöhnlich für die
Jahreszeit und da könnte zum Beispiel
die Nordsee ein Mitgrund dafür sein denn
die ist im Moment zwei Grad wärmer als
normal das Sturmtief überquert morgen
den Nordwesten die Deutsche Bucht und
zieht bis nach Skandinavien wir müssen
zwei Dinge im Auge behalten zum einen
das hauptsturmfeld südlich des Tiefs und
die Gewitter vor und an seiner Kaltfront
zunächst zum Wind der gesamte Nordwesten
bekommt es morgen mit mindestens
stürmischen Bühnen und Sturmböen um 80
km pro Stunde zu tun das ganze geht aber
bisschen zu 130 km pro Stunde also
Orkanböen und nach aktuellem Stand sind
die am wahrscheinlichsten an der
Nordseeküste ganz genau wissen wir das
aber erst morgen auf jeden Fall kann das
z.B zu Verkehrsbehinderungen und
umgestürzten Bäumen führen wie sie es
mit der Kaltfront aus die erreicht schon
in der zweiten Nachthälfte den Westen
mit Schauer mit dem Regen und
eingelagerten Gewittern die ziehen zwar
schnell haben punktuell aber Starkregen
und Sturmböen mit dabei morgen breitet
sich das Ganze dann schnell nach Osten
hinaus ist nachmittags hier auch schon
durchgezogen am längsten blitzt und
donnert ist noch im Südosten außerdem
gibt es im Tagesverlauf den länger
anhaltenden Regen in der Nähe des Tiefs
sie im Nordwesten in der Mitte lockert
es aber auch schnell wieder auf die
Temperaturen liegen zwischen 17 und 27
Grad ab Donnerstag ist der Sturm vorbei
dann wird es heiß zum Wochenende wie
lange diese Hitze aber bleibt ist noch
ungewiss kommen Sie gut durch diese
wetterwoche tschüss